RISE IN CASES COME RESTRICTIONS.
>> Sean: WE WATCH THE FULL
INTERVIEW ON FOX NATION, DR.
SAPHIER THANK YOU.
DEVELOPMENTS OVERSEE.
MILITIA FIRING ROCKETS AT U.S.
FORCES IN SYRIA FOLLOWING THIS
WEEK'S AIR STRIKES.
SAVAGES STILL BEING ASSESSED AT
THE U.S. BASE IN EASTERN SYRIA.
SO FAR, NO INJURIES REPORTED.
SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR COME I'M NOT SURE IF I'M
ALLOWED TO TALK ABOUT AND OFF
THE RECORD CONVERSATION WE HAD
TO, BUT THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT YOU
PREDICTED TO ME WOULD
HAPPEN.
>> YEAH, SO HERE IS THE
GAME PLAN.
NUMBER ONE THE IRANIANS ARE
PLAYING PRESIDENT BIDEN LIKE A
FIDDLE.
THE AYATOLLAH, SEAN A RELIGIOUS.
HITLER WANTED A MASTER RATE
APPEAR THE AYATOLLAH ONCE A
MASTER RELIGION.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DRIVE US OUT
OF SYRIA AND IRAQ TO DOMINATE
SYRIA, IRAQ, IRAN.
THEY ARE TRYING TO BUILD A
WEAPON TO HOLD THE WORLD HOSTAGE
AND ONE DAY DESTROY THE STATE OF
ISRAEL.
THEY ARE ON THE PATH TO
ACCOMPLISH ALL OF THAT UNLESS WE
MAKE A CORRECTION NOW.
I'VE NEVER BEEN MORE WORRIED
THAN I AM RIGHT NOW ABOUT A WAR
BETWEEN IRAN AND ISRAEL.
>> Sean: I THINK THE BIGGEST
AND MOST UNDERREPORTED STORY WAS
THE TRAINEES, THE RUSSIANS ARE
NOW GIVING WEAPONS TO THE
IRANIAN SO THEY CAN FIGHT THEIR
PROXY WAR AND THE REST OF THE
MIDDLE EAST.
I DON'T KNOW, AM I THE ONLY
PERSON ON NATIONAL TV THAT SEEMS
TO NOTICE THAT IS A BIG PROBLEM?
>> YOU ARE THE ONLY ONE THAT
TALKS ABOUT A LOT OF THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, THE RUSSIANS AND THE
CHINESE BELIEVE THAT WHAT IS BAD
FOR US IS GOOD FOR THEM HERE
THEY ARE MAKING A MISTAKE WITH
FAUCI.
AGAIN THEY IRANIANS HAVE TO
DOMINATE SYRIA FROM IRAQ, AND
IRAN.
THEY WANT TO BUILD A WEAPON TO
HOLD THE WORLD HOSTAGE AND
DESTROYED THE STATE OF ISRAEL.
THE STATE OF ISRAEL IS IN A BAD
SPOT HERE.
HOW MUCH LONGER DO THEY WAIT
BEFORE THEY ACT?
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN TRUST THE
UNITED STATES WITH ISRAEL
SECURITY.
WHAT BIDEN DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
WHO THE AYATOLLAH IS HERE THE
AYATOLLAH HAS A GAME PLAN THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE CHRISTIANS,,
MODERATE MUSLIMS, SHE WORE
SUNNI.
THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT EVENT
SINCE THE 30s AND WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO KEEP IRAN ON THE ROPES
AND A CHANCE TO KEEP THEM IN A
BOX BUT EVERYDAY THEY GET
STRONGER BECAUSE BIDEN DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND THE NATURE OF THE
THREAT.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, IF I'M
RIGHT AND MY OBSERVATIONS AND
THE OBSERVATIONS OF MANY PEOPLE
ARE CORRECT THAT JOE SEEMS OUT
OF IT ON A REGULAR BASIS, THOSE
ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW STRONG
HE IS AND HOW CAPABLE HE IS OF
EVEN UNDERSTANDING IT, THEN IT
RAISES QUESTIONS WHO WAS MAKING
THE DECISIONS.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT THESE
HOSTILE REGIME FROM RUSSIA TO
CHINA TO NORTH KOREA TO THE
IRANIAN AND ERRATIC ISLAMIC
GROUPS, THEY ARE FEELING
SOMEWHAT EMBOLDENED NOW.
IS THAT A WRONG OBSERVATION?
>> WE ARE CUTTING OUR MILITARY
BUDGET, INCREASE SPENDING BY 17%
PURE DIFFERENT SPENDING LESS
THAN INFLATION.
WE ARE WITHDRAWING FROM
AFGHANISTAN WHERE WE HAD A FEW
THOUSAND TROOPS TO KEEP AL QAEDA
AND ISIS AT BAY.
HERE IS MY MESSAGE.
THE IRANIAN REGIME ARE
RELIGIOUS'S.
THEY WOULD KILL ALL THE IF THEY
COULD APPEAR THEY WOULD DOMINATE
THE MIDEAST WITH A FORMER
RELIGION TO MAKE THE WORLD
UNBEARABLE PLACE TO LIVE AND
COME AFTER US.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DRIVE US OUT
OF THE MIDEAST AND THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT BIDEN IS WEAK
AND MAKING THE WORLD A DANGEROUS
PLACE BY SHOWING WEAKNESS.
WHEN TRUMP KILLED SULLA MEANING
IT RESETS A RELATIONSHIP WITH
IRAN.
EVERYTHING TRUMP H